ich
bin gemobbt wurde ich bin
ausgeschlossen wurde ich bin ausgenutzt
wurde sie so ziemlich alles was
irgendwie geschlachtet wo nicht
sie bin oder einfach garen will er sie
das
oder sowas
[Musik]
Depression ganz fest die Gefühl von
Traurigkeit Freudlosigkeit keine E-Mail
abwerge Gosse Aggressivität gut
verunglücken sind und ich kann nicht
wissen
ich bin einfach
sein der in die Welt hinauszieht und
ganz passabel aussieht mit Schild im
festen Griff
[Musik]
Ort gefunden haben wo ich mich gerade
zurückziehe einfach mal
[Applaus]
dass einigermaßen
hallo
Süße okay gut
passiert Sachen zu finden wo wir helfen
danke
und ich einfach Angst gehabt dass das
dann passiert und
es wird parallelisierte Moment
an
einfach funktioniert im Chemie bin aber
wir wirklich es Elend
und dann hat Mama irgendwann Zeit
sie
nimmer und sie hat einfach auch gut
die sozialpädagogische Einrichtung
wird zum Anker für Joya
mit sehr oftmals Verhaltensmuster mit
oder
Ängste
Verletzungen aufgrund von einem was
passiert ist wieder der Geschichte und
den hilf mir deine wir mit dem und
lernen damit
eines halben Jahres kann Roja hier zur
Ruhe kommen und gesund werden
wie sie verlieren immer mehr Jugendliche
in der Schweiz den Glauben an die
Zukunft
2022 geben erstmals weniger als 50%
aller Jugendlichen an optimistisch in
die Zukunft zu blicken
[Musik]
die Stadt Zürich hat deshalb ein
Pilotprojekt gestartet
ganz herzlich Willkommen
von der Verfassung bleiben
wer kennt schon bemütig vom Wort
Depression
wer kennt schon das Wort
was heißt das
ja genau das sind jetzt alles
verschiedene Bereiche Lebensbereichen
verschiedene Kulturen ich habe ihm im
Leben gemacht alles gut wo erfolgreich
sind
[Musik]
und Höflichkeit das ist jedes feucht die
Mighty oder richtet ja mir ist über
Wochen Monate so schlecht Gange was soll
die richtige Depression Gott depressive
Episode Phase und jederzeit die Burg
Sozialarbeiter okay
die Pandemie belastet viele Menschen
unter 18-Jährige leiden am meisten
64% geben eine sehr hohe oder hohe
psychische Belastung an bei den 18 bis
39-Jährigen sind es 48 Prozent bei den
40 bis 64-Jährigen leiden noch 39 bei
den über 65-Jährigen nur noch 27% unter
sehr hoher oder hoher psychischer
Belastung
bei den Jungen hat sich der Anteil der
psychisch belasteten im ersten Lockdown
verdoppelt im zweiten sogar verdreifacht
dabei verstärkt die Pandemie auch
soziale und gesundheitliche
Ungleichheiten
auch emil ist betroffen in der Pandemie
gleitet er in eine schwere Essstörung in
eine Krise die er längst hinter sich
glaubte
[Musik]
Emil und Leonie haben sich vor Jahren in
der Klinik für Jugendpsychiatrie
kennengelernt seither haben sie eine
tiefe Freundschaft aufgebaut
Leonie kennt die s-problematik aus
eigener Erfahrung lange hat sie diese
für sich behalten
und das ist
eigentlich so gern machen
[Musik]
dank ihrer eigenen Erfahrungen konnte
sie vor einem Jahr Emil aus der Krise
helfen
argumentieren werden
[Musik]
und dann machst Handy auf und dann sehe
ich erstmal so diskut mit so mega viel
Filter wie viel bearbeiten sind und bis
sofort
mit dem Alter also dann google ich mal
ja wenn ich mich jetzt eigentlich ab und
du bist Jugendlicher
zwei Wochen und dann bescheid sagen
[Musik]
emil hat eine lange Leidensgeschichte
seine Pubertät ist schmerzvoll
Fragen stellt und das sehr einfach
geschafft hat einfach den Wahnsinn
zufrieden
[Musik]
aber nicht normal
sehr oft einfach unzulänglich Gefühl
das habe ich gesagt
wurde bin ich einmal ein bisschen
dass ich das was
der Emil fertig machen also
ich bin immer weniger gegangen also
Schatz anfangen
mehrere Klinikaufenthalte Folgen zu
seinem Schutz muss Emil im Isolierzimmer
übernachten
ich bin von mir eingeführt also
die ganze aufgestaute Emotionen
[Musik]
heute kann Emil sein Leben selbst in die
Hand nehmen und
Zukunftspläne schmieden
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ich bin mega schön und ich fühle mich
mega attraktiv und dein Tag trifft genau
sieht mega komisch aus und kann mega
absur die Positionen
überhaupt nicht schön obwohl so rein
physikalisches
[Musik]
nein wieso Therapie schon
das Problem mit zur Perfektionismus
[Musik]
mich selber machen was schöner Logo das
ist einerseits
Akzeptanz und so psychische Sachen statt
körperliche Sachen
verstanden
[Musik]
vielleicht
kann dich ein Held sein der in die Welt
hinaus zieht und ganz passabel aussieht
[Musik]
ich finde es einfach mit Gefühl
oberflächlich ausdrucken
[Musik]
und dann
haben wir lernen über euch dass man
eigene Emotionen muss jetzt leider zu
Ende und dann und dann viel als in die
Probleme darauf projiziert wirklich
Trainer das Lernen
und du machst einfach so
zu lieb geworden ist und
einfach einfach Depression damals
[Musik]
zum Vater gefällt teilweise schaffen
und auch unglaubt gefühlt
und das glaubst
einfach und das ist der größte Grund
ist das lochkind
in seiner Verzweiflung Gerät benennen in
eine Essstörung mehrere zusammenbreche
folgen schließlich begibt er sich in
ambulante Therapie
seine drei Geschwister sind bereits
ausgezogen als Ben in seine Maturaarbeit
schreibt ein selbst komponiertes Lied
dem alleinerziehenden Vater gewidmet
[Musik]
hat er mir gesagt dass er stolz ist dass
ich richtig Talent haben nach den vielen
Jahren
hat er jetzt endlich Zeit
für mich so viel mehr als nur das Lied
[Musik]
hallo hallo
doch dann kann ich mir geschrieben
und dann klar
das einzige fotoschuhe
trotzdem und dank der Therapie schafft
bennen die Matura und den Sprung nach
Hamburg
vielleicht könnte ich ein Held sein der
in die Welt hinaus zieht
und ganz passabel aussieht mit Schild im
festen Griff ein Wikinger womöglich ein
Kerl mit rauerseele der riecht wie eine
Makrele
auf seinem Drachenschiff ich setzte kurz
ich stehe über den Dingen
das wäre so toll und das gibt mir die
toll wenn ich das bin und dann auf
einmal kommst du wieder in die Realität
und denkst
bin ich nicht ich bin nur ein oder
danke ist richtig was anfangen
wo bin ich wirklich wer bin ich wirklich
und wo bin ich wirklich
wer auf die Bühne möchte ist ganz
besonders mit Kritik und Leistungsdruck
konfrontiert damit umzugehen hat bennen
gelernt
ich kann vieles gelernt wird
Therapiestunde
wohne ich jetzt umsetzen werde vor allem
merke wenn es passiert also merke
eigentlich Fußball
schon wissen was passiert wenn ich mich
jetzt rede Phase aber Single LAN oder
es ist einfach
sofort einfach ins Keller anstatt nicht
der Betrieb
[Musik]
um den Umgang mit Kritik zu üben bietet
die Schule das Fach mental care an
[Musik]
Zeit ich bin neu
doch und alle anderen
[Musik]
Leistungsdruck soziale Medien corvit
Klimakrise Krieg das ist viel Druck auf
ein junges Gemüt auch bei Joya bricht
die Krise während der Pandemie aus
ihre Eltern und die jüngere Schwester
versuchen ihr beizustehen trotzdem
gleitet teuer in eine tiefe Depression
die Pandemie erzwingt den Rückzug
Schulunterricht im Zimmer keine
Abgrenzung zwischen Schule und Freizeit
und wenig Aussicht auf unbeschwerte
Ablenkung
[Musik]
auf der soziale Plattformen und die Asam
wieder so und so viel manche ermordet
wurde durch
extrem Angst bekommen
bin ich gewobt wurde früher
sechste Primarschule es hat wie so
einführerin und ich bin immer mega
gebrochen und meine Eltern das immer
gesagt doch einfach einmal nein aber ich
möchte nicht getraut ich wieder zurück
hatte niemals die Stärke kommt gerade
will sie mich so aber gemacht hat hat
sie einfach genau der Herr Truppe und
schafft mich so mega
beeinfluss und strangulieren
und
ja
ja hätten wir auch nicht trotzdem
geschafft
es
nicht
einfach mega leid für mich
sie ist so unschuldig sie
ist mega schlimm
bei jungen Menschen steigen die
Hospitalisierungen wegen psychischer
Störungen in den vergangenen Jahren
immer weiter an die Pandemie verschärft
diesen Trend
zum ersten Mal übertreffen die
Hospitalisierungen aufgrund psychischer
Störungen diejenigen von Verletzungen
besonders häufig betroffen sind junge
Frauen
in den pandemiejahren steigt die Zahl
der stationären Spitalaufenthalte wegen
psychischer Störungen bei den Mädchen um
sechs Prozent im Folgejahr um
beispiellose 26%
[Musik]
bei den Jungen beträgt der Anstieg
lediglich zwei und dann 6%
. es herrscht ein Notstand an
therapieplätzen und Fachleuten ein neues
Zentrum in Zürich bietet Soforthilfe für
Jugendliche kaum eröffnet ist der
Betrieb bereits voll ausgelastet
guten Morgen
am Wochenende
die hat ganz fest
wieder Stationen
[Musik]
in der neuen Station erhalten die
Jugendlichen eine intensive und
individuelle Therapie
aber es ist sag jetzt mal es ist eine
Plastik aber ich denke jede ganze
Psychiatrie Landschaft müssen
die Jugendlichen
die Jugendlichen leben im Live einen
beinahe normalen Alltag mit Schule und
Freizeit
ihre Bezugspersonen sind in die
Behandlung eng eingebunden
im geschützten Rahmen können die
Jugendlichen neue Perspektiven aufbauen
und man weiß auch wenn es einem schlecht
gerade einfach immer da wow halt auch
irgendwie zur Lust und es geht einfach
auch die Sicherheit so wenn man
stationär ist und manchmal
beschäftigt und ich glaube das hilft
auch noch Strukturen
sie kommen wegen Depressionen
Angststörungen oder Suizidgedanken in
ihrer Krise sollen sie früh aufgefangen
werden damit sie rasch in ihr Umfeld
zurückkehren können das Zusammensein mit
anderen Betroffenen hilft die eigene
Situation zu akzeptieren
ich glaube es ist einfach nur als großes
Tabuthema sehr oft nur Vorurteil
gegenüber gewisse psychische
Instabilitäten und ich finde das auch
nicht richtig weil es ist
erstens Thema will es geht auch sehr
viele Leute wurden auch so sie beginnt
oder
sich selber
auch was Jugendliche Gleichaltrigen
antun kann psychischer Krankheiten
auslösen
alle Formen von Mobbing haben in den
vergangenen Jahren zugenommen
ausschließen auslachen drohen sexuelle
Belästigung schlagen oder Dinge
zerstören
die Druckmittel sind vielfältig und
perfid das daraus entstandene Leid groß
ja dann
ist schwierig
ich schätze das extrem billig finde es
einfach cool mit dem zahlen und ich habe
jetzt mit dem Bobby auch nur angere
Beziehung aufgebaut
er mich immer mega begleitet hat wenn
ich mich zum Beispiel
gegangen
sie mit Homeoffice und so vieles rundum
bis jetzt wann sie das noch benötigt
genau
passiert siehst du ja 17,5 17 und
ähm auf der großen Hilflosigkeit
wie immer
das hat Angst gemacht aber Angst dass
sie sich ein bisschen
[Musik]
sehr
verzweifelt gemacht ich habe
Angstgedanken dass ich mir
dass ich einfach nur tiefer ins Loch
hingehen und ich bin wirklich so das ist
schlimmer wird das ist so ist und
einfach so mega Hilflosigkeit ich kann
nicht mit dir passiert
für Sie
Therapie jetzt finden und und
früher bis im Herbst zum ersten Gespräch
heute nach einem Jahr Auszeit ist Steuer
zurück in Schule und Alltag
was ich merke
und
undibilität bleibt und das finde ich und
ja auf der Wunsch da dass das
aber insgesamt wirklich besser
ja
es ist ein heiliges Prozess und ich habe
einfach Methode gefunden haben zum mit
zur Sache und zwar
Freundeskreis
liegt das jetzt vor der soziale Medien
oder was auch immer sondern wirklich
aktiv gegen dass ich noch nicht
dass mir noch nicht schlecht geworden
mit und
jetzt merke ja jetzt ich hier gerade Tag
und dann sage ich auch
guter Tag aber
[Musik]
und jetzt ist es schon einiges weniger
abgespannt wie ruhiger was er ruhiger so
ja
oder was meinst Du ruhiger
und so geht Dich nicht beunruhigen 20
hinter mir wirklich nur ab und zu sorgen
machen ist wenn du mit dem Dorf
unterwegs ist aber nicht wohl eine gute
Fahrt ich weiß wie gut es einfach sonst
gibt es
Hauptsache
irgendwie sich dort schade wie früher
gut zum Chöre ja
nicht sehr viel
[Musik]
ich habe immer noch das Problem damit
mir selber können ich da hey gut gemacht
kein Diskussion ist mir egal
fallen Schuhe sehr gut aber eben kein
neuer Problem Mann irgendwie eine Karte
ist
das Problem dass sie nicht bekommen aber
so ein großes ganze Wahrzeichen
[Musik]
ist der Fahrer gibt mir
Freiheit und Unabhängigkeit großes Stück
Friedhof
als Persönlichkeit fühle ich mich so
viel Festigkeit
in ungefähr bin und
was ich im Bett und was mir wichtig ist
was mir nicht wert sind
genaue planen oder Lageplan wie ich
genau heute gegangen
welche Richtung
[Musik]
wie Emil mussten auch bennen und seine
Schulkollegin Lilly lernen Vertrauen in
sich und ihren Körper zu gewinnen ja und
dann
Feierabends dass man ihn auch nie
nachgefragt
in der Ausbildung gibt viele Leute die
eine gesunde Beziehung zu ihrem Körper
haben es ist nur schwierig das Maß zu
finden auch mit dem was man da täglich
vermittelt bekommt also wir kriegen oft
gesagt dass man so auszusehen hat oder
sich so zu bewegen hat
ja man muss da trotzdem irgendwie noch
bei sich bleiben
[Gelächter]
früher hatte ich ziemlich Probleme mit
Essen und mit was ich esse wie viel ich
esse
ob ich überhaupt esse das kam vom Tanzen
weil ich habe Latein und Standard
bettkampf gemacht damals als ich 12 war
13 14 und ich hatte eine feste
Tanzpartnerin und wir waren wirklich gut
und hatten schnell auch Erfolge sind so
kinderturniere Jugendturniere und dann
waren wir ganz oft zweiter Platz
und irgendwann war sie Zeit einfach
nicht verstanden warum sind immer
zweiter Platz und nie erste und dann
mein Lehrer irgendwann das begründet
damit dass wir zwei Pudding sind und hat
dann gesagt dass wir einfach
Pudding sind und dieses Wort ist mir
immer im Kopf geblieben hat gesagt wir
schwabbeln und dann habe ich aufgehört
zu essen und so fing alles an
es gab Fälle wo die Ballettunterricht
stand und Sprünge gemacht habe und dann
er lehre mich angeschrieben hat mit den
Worten Schwabbel Schwabbel Schwabbel um
mich das einfach als ich Standard habe
einfach angefangen zu weinen im
Unterricht und sie meinte damit nur im
Nachhinein kann ich das total verstehen
sie meinte nur so meine
innenbeinmuskulatur anspannen aber für
mich damals war das der größte Auslöser
ever ich habe stundenlang geweint ich
bin danach nicht mehr zum Unterricht
gegangen ich habe nicht mehr rein
getraut ist einfach jedes Mal wenn ich
die Frau gesehen habe hatte ich einfach
Panik
und es hat auch die Liebe zum Tanz
genommen für ein paar Monaten
und das war schlimm irgendwann mit der
Zeit konnte ich dann verstehen was die
gemeint hat und auch mit einem Freunden
auch geklärt haben
vielleicht einen morgen merke ich will
nicht aufstehen ich will mich depressiv
ich will einfach versinken dann tue ich
das nicht sondern stehe ich auf oder ich
lasse es kurz zu
aber komm irgendwann nach diesem doch
wieder raus an dem Tag weil ich weiß
dass dann nächsten Morgen noch schwerer
sein wird aufzustehen
und wenn ich merke ich habe ein problem
mein Körper das alles anfangen wenn ich
das merke wenn es sich sofort fast tot
es irgendwas geiles was ich will und
dann geht's mir gut dann denke okay
blendend aber es ist wirklich das
Problem killen bevor es entstehen kann
[Gelächter]
kürzlich hat bennen einen zweiten
Berufszweig für sich entdeckt
meine Konfektionsgröße meine Brustumfang
du musst gucken ob eine Seite sind ja
gut so anders ja so danke schön
ich habe morning erst als habe ich nie
getraut dazu weil ich nie dachte ich
wäre schön genug dafür und dann habe ich
im Sommer erst bei Headshots machen
musste für meinen Job
modeling entdeckt und ich bin so
aufgeregt vor der Kamera so viel Spaß
gemacht und ich dachte echt das neue
Berufszeit nicht eingehen würde und da
möchte ich so gefreut dass sie
aufgenommen wurde und das jetzt auch
umsetzen kann
die sind alle voll schön
danke schön also ich brauche halt
einfach eins vom Null Gesicht drauf ist
ein halbkörper und
Ganzkörperfoto sonst
irgendwie nicht
Körper drauf also ich mag meinen Körper
wer ist ich mag mich wie ich bin und
merke auch dass es gut ankommt aber ich
arbeite auch viel dafür dass ich das
gesunde Verhältnis behalten kann
[Musik]
seine Grenzen zu akzeptieren sich nicht
zu überfordern bleibt nicht einfach
beim Training hat sich pennen am Knie
verletzt deshalb muss er beim
Weihnachtsspiel auf der Bühne auf einige
Einsätze verzichten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und ich kann so viel mal einfach
vor Schönheit vorstellen einfach so Spaß
gemacht hat und es hat irgendwie mir gar
nicht gar nicht weiter
dass ich so wenig gemacht habe aber
[Musik]
für dich gesehen
und jetzt freue mich dass ich wieder
kann mal wieder mal oder
und ja bin gespannt
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
es hat eigentlich alle Auszeichnung
sondern ich kann gut
[Musik]
und jetzt ich will optimistischer